lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
enseñarles una manera de restar números
es diferente que la técnica de reagrupar
esto se parece más a lo que pasa en mi
cabeza cuando hago estas restas
probablemente esto no lo van a ver en la
escuela así que tengan cuidado cuando
vean este vídeo porque habrá personas
que no estén de acuerdo en que les
enseñe esto la razón por qué lo hago es
para que entiendan que no hay sólo una
manera de resolver los problemas si
entienden los principios lo que los
números representan y pueden hacer cosas
con los números haciendo que tenga
sentido entonces no tendrán problema y
en esta técnica no vamos a reagrupar
sino que vamos a empezar por la posición
de las centenas y simplemente vamos a
avanzar por ejemplo tengo 301 y lo
primero que hago es restar 100
así que 300 menos 100 es igual a 200
ahora voy a restar 60 y lo que tengo que
pensar es cuánto es 20 menos 6
0 6 esto representa 200 menos 60
entonces 20 menos 6 es igual a 14
lo que hago es restar y ahora tengo 14
ahora simplemente tengo que pensar
cuánto es 141 menos 9 y esto tal vez es
un poco más difícil de lo que están
acostumbrados a hacer en cálculo mental
pero 141 9 es igual a 132 el resultado
es 132 y vamos a resolver la que sigue
con la misma técnica los animo a que
pausa en el vídeo y que lo hagan ustedes
solos con esta técnica
9 12 7 900 menos 200 es igual a 700
luego 71 menos 8 es igual a 11 menos 83
así que aquí nos queda 63 y ahora
tenemos que restar 633 menos 613 menos
67 así que el resultado es 627 y para
terminar traten de pausar el vídeo y
hacer esta última ustedes mismos aquí no
tenemos nada que restar en las centenas
así que vamos directamente a restar 72
menos 8 que representa realmente 720
menos 80 pero pensemos en términos de 72
menos 8 12 menos 84 así que 72 menos 8
es igual a 64 y lo que queda lo hacemos
de la misma manera 641 menos 8 41 menos
8 es igual a 33 esto es un poco de
cálculo mental
y el resultado aquí es 633